with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
worried about application performance
cache it then stay tuned because here's
the rewind when developing an
application there are several things
that are fundamental speed response time
availability and cost to run it doesn't
matter how good your application is if
it stutters or takes too long to respond
it'll never succeed in memory caching is
a common pattern you see to achieve that
performance that you need in memory
caching helps reduce latency and cost by
taking frequently accessed data and
retrieving it from memory when possible
rather than disk there's quite a bit
going on beneath the surface to properly
do caching
so this means that while it's a common
concept there's plenty to learn about
optimization and your options
particularly around using a Redis
process Redis is an open source in
memory data structure store that means
it holds anything you put into it in
active memory instead of on disk the
Redis is popular because it's more than
just a key value store it supports a
bunch of different data structures it
has high availability and persistence
Redis is usable for many different use
cases not just for caching when you're
moving to the cloud getting rid of
infrastructure management is often top
of the mind and that includes managing
and monitoring your cache so that's
where Google's cloud memory store comes
in memory stores a managed solution
fully compatible with the Redis protocol
which means you get all the awesome of
Redis without any of the management
memory store helps you optimize in three
main ways since it's a managed service
one updates and security patching are
all taken care of
- it's got high availability and
reliability with automatic failover and
replication and three its scalable and
it's secure cloud memory storage comes
in two different packages to suit your
needs
first the basic tier it's a standalone
regional instance of Redis and then the
standards here is a cross zone
replicated instance since the GA
launched six months ago many updates
have been added to memory store
including manual failover for testing
access from App Engine second generation
runtimes more regions metrics and some
compliance certifications but these
expansions don't stop there the team is
currently working to add many more
capabilities to memory store things like
shared VPC an instance level
authentication and Redis clustering in
addition to a live demo showing how
simple it is to set all of this up the
talk goes over some best practices for
storing data eviction policies and
memory management and then a breakdown
of what to monitor from stackdriver
things like CPU usage and alerts keys
present and memory fail overs and how to
best scale based on growth if you'd like
to see the full talk check out the link
in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the cloud YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for watching
[Music]